okay so this is a talk about peer
prediction which we can think about as a
problem that I think is unusual because
it's both very fascinating to study but
it's also I hope I convinced you of
practically important and interesting so
informational station without
verification let me give you some
examples I could be encouraging people
to deploy sensors to participate in a
sensing system so think about a sensing
system around the city why without
verification I don't want to assume that
I have access to any ground truth
information about the information local
to the sensors in the city I could be
looking to collect emotional responses
to video content this is something you
could imagine would be useful for
marketing for a kind of improving what
Hollywood is doing I could be looking to
complete a consumer survey asking you
what features of a digital camera would
you find interesting
I could be crowdsourcing feedback on my
search algorithms is my tweak I've made
to my product search algorithm worse or
better than the last version of the
algorithm
I could be peer grading in MOOCs so in
all of these settings I think either
you'll agree with me that it's true that
there's no access to some verifiable
ground truth that's kind of no there's
nowhere to ground the information that
that's reported to the system or at
least you would agree that it's costly
to get that information so we're in a
setting where effort I'm also further
going to assume that if I ask users in
the the sensing example I'm asking you
to keep your sensing device
well-maintained so that's costly in the
emotional response to content I'm asking
you to tell me whether you found the
scene I've just shown you exciting or
and if nervous making or other things in
looking in the consumer survey I'm
asking you to really introspect about
what's important
you so I think in in in these settings
we can imagine that it's it's costly for
you to invest efforts in this task so
I'll need to somehow reward informative
responses and the thing that I'm going
to worry about is that the reward scheme
that I design might unintentionally
introduce additional bad equilibria so
I'm going to have to pay for information
and I want to pay for information in a
way where by doing that I don't
unintended ly introduce new things that
are happening where I'm getting that say
bad information because the participants
maximize their payments by providing bad
information I'm gonna worry about
collusion as well okay so how can we do
this how can we solve this problem of
information elicitation without
verification there are two kinds of
mechanisms in the literature this is a
problem that's been studied for quite a
long time one class of mechanisms are
minimal meaning that I'm only going to
ask agents for information we'll call
that their signal so we're only going to
collect signal information second class
of mechanisms we'll just call them non
minimal ask for signal information and
for the belief that you have about the
signal that another agent in the system
will receive so say we're grading
assignments you think the grade is a B
what is your distribution you now place
on the grade that will be assigned by
another random person in the population
i interested in practical information
elicitation without verification so I'm
just going to talk about minimal
mechanisms in this talk so mechanisms
that only ask for information not
beliefs okay so the simplest scheme for
this which is called simple output
agreement and if you've ever heard or
played the ESP game you've seen this
let me semi also set up the model just a
little bit but we'll get back to this in
some detail I want you to think about
two agents these agents you can think
about as being randomly sampled from
some large population
and I want you to think about a joint
distribution on the signals of those of
those agents okay so here the joint
signals of the joint the joint signal
distribution here is P the random
variables X are the signals that agent
for get the realized values the signals
I or J will typically denote I for the
realized value of the signal for agent 1
and J for agent 2 we're interested in
setting is where the signals are
discrete and are non binary so there
were more than just yes or no answers
and the simplest scheme you might think
about is design a game where I take
reports so Costas makes the report and
Eric makes the report in the binary
setting the report for one or two and if
you agree I pay you one if you don't
agree I don't pay you okay this is a
simple output agreement mechanism let's
say that one of the things were
interested in is strictly proper
mechanisms where truthful reporting is a
Bayes national courtroom when this
mechanism strictly proper when it's true
for reporting a Bayes Nash equilibrium
well what you have to think about is
when you get signal 1 conditioned on you
having signal 1 what is your belief that
the other agent will get will get signal
1 or signal 2 and so if the conditional
probability of the other agent getting 1
conditioned on you getting 1 is greater
than conditional probability of the
other agent getting two conditions are
you getting one you'll happily report a
1 in that case that will maximize your
expected payment so that's the condition
that's needed in this setting let me see
if I can kill that for strict properness
the creep you see if you could use Adobe
I think that might be the problem
because you're in the Apple preview
instead of the okay so this is a
condition that we need you know this is
this is this is not always gonna hold so
that's one problem with this scheme you
can think about it if if if it's very
unlikely generally that the the signal
and the Joint Distribution is wrong then
even conditioned on you getting a one
you may place more weight on the other
and the other region receiving signal
too that's one problem but a bigger
problem the problem that I'm going to
I'm going to focus on in this talk is
yes there is a strict space Nash
equilibrium here when this condition
holds is truthful there is an
uninformative equilibrium where we both
say one all the time the Nash
equilibrium that has a higher expected
payment at one all the time so that's
the problem that's one reason why you
might not actually like to use the
scheme in practice okay it's all or
every time I don't get any information
the signal is reported and not
correlated in any way with the true
signals okay so this problem was solved
this was solved and this this was the
paper that introduced the peer
prediction method this was solved by
saying okay I'm gonna do the following
I'm gonna receive report all want
revenge on one eye is the mechanism will
form the conditional belief that agent
one should have about the signal of the
other agents and I will use this belief
in a proper scoring rule and I will
score you as agent Wan using that belief
against the reported signal of the other
agent if you think about it if you've
seen proper scoring rules before you
think about it and if you also assume
that the model of the mechanism is
correct that is it's correctly updating
and forming a belief on your behalf
based on your report this is going to
strictly align incentives in equilibrium
so what did this do this is now strictly
proper I don't need to say strictly
proper if X Y Z and is true
it's strictly proper um but now the
designer needs for model well that's
hard to motivate in practice and we
still have this problem of uninformative
equilibria in fact if you write down the
payoff matrix corresponding to this
method you're now gonna see that where
is the old payoff matrix was ones and
zeroes there are multiple numbers in
this payoff matrix and you will
coordinate on the one with the highest
value and that will be a Nash
equilibrium so we haven't solved that
problem this is a scheme that relaxes
the knowledge requirement so there are
various schemes that do that this is a
scheme that looks like output agreement
but rather than paying a dollar
pays a dollar divided by the signal
prior in other words if we both agree on
something that is ex ante I'm likely
will get paid more this is ivory firts
this is the one over prior mechanism now
going to show you the math behind this
but suffice to say that this is strictly
proper always for binary signals for
more than two signals you need some
technical conditions it looks a little
bit better than the MRD
mechanism the one I described on the
last slide because the designer doesn't
need as much information designer only
needs the marginal probabilities now but
it still has this problem it still has
these bad and informative equilibria
it's very clear here I think you're
going to coordinate on the play where
the marginal probability was the
smallest and get paid a lot of money
assume it is here so I I'm assuming in
all of these example so the payment is
the same to both players if it's not
symmetric you can write down two numbers
are often on one number
okay so I think hope this opening
narrative leads to a set of desiderata
that we'd like for real-world peer
prediction mechanisms we might need to
be minimal so we only ask for signal
information we like them to be proper
perhaps we'd care about strictly proper
any of those a strict equilibrium to be
truthful
we've like low knowledge requirement
from the designer these kind of issues
about coordination on uninformative high
payments equilibria suggest there are
other properties we care about as well
and this talk is going to be about
achieving these additional properties so
the other properties we might care about
is strong truthfulness which will say
that being truthful playing the truthful
strategy profile has a list of much
expected payment of anything else that
could be done and if there's a tie then
you must be playing a permutation
strategy so you must be playing 1 maps
to - 2 maps to 3 3 maps to 1
ok so strong truthfulness is essentially
going to say the truthfulness gives you
strictly more payments than any other
pair of strategies the players could
adopt I'm not saying any other pair of
strategies in equilibrium just any other
pair of strategies that's a strong
property inform truthfulness is a
slightly weakened form of that it's
still going to insist the being truthful
provides the same expected payment at
least as much expected payments as any
other joint play and now it's also going
to insist that if you play an
uninformative strategy you have strictly
less expected payment so what's the non
informative strategy it's a strategy
where your strategy doesn't depend in
anyway on the signal in the world that
you've received so in other words this
uninformative property this this this
informed truthfulness property takes the
design stance that's the thing we're
really trying to achieve here is to get
players to participate is to get players
to invest efforts in acquiring a signal
and that if conditioned on having
invested effort to acquire a signal they
have the same expected payment for both
being truthful as other things they
could do then they'll choose to be
truthful because truthfulness will
somehow be focal amongst the class of
informs play so f of informed
truthfulness property Nicole deviations
being unilateral versus pairwise
deviations are you saying that my
truthful report with any report of the
other guy should be better for me than
any pair of things that we otherwise
could do or yes I'm going to provide
some formal definitions but yes that's
that's roughly what I'm saying and we'd
also like to handle heterogeneity so
we'd also like agents to somehow differ
in the way they respond to the world so
that goes to cost us this question we're
going to assume we're going to be
willing to assume that there are
multiple tasks there are multiple
independently sample tasks that agents
are performing it's like you're grading
more than one assignment
so what do we know about this it's what
I think we know about this problem York
of all things had a paper where they
said that if there are at least four
agents even just with one task not
multiple tasks in the binary setting
they can knock out these pure
uninformative equilibrium
however they ignore mixed equilibrium
and they were only in the binary setting
and the design needs access to the model
of the world there's a paper by death
group Turin Ghosh 2013 which will
provide the background so the technical
work that we do in this paper there in
the multiple tasks environments they
achieve that the properties that I say
are important they achieve strict
properness and strong truthfulness but
there were only in the binary true
fulfilling they're only in the binary
signal setting so only yes/no answers
there's a paper by radinovich and
faulting it's also in the multiple tasks
setting they now do extend to multi
signal and they get strict properness
and strong truthfulness among symmetric
strategies so again we'll get to the
formal definition of that but the catch
here is that they only achieve this for
asymptotically large numbers of tasks
there's a paper by Campbell that out
including the house shy who's over over
there in the audience very similar
setting actually their results due to
part a little bit from the radon of edge
and faulting setting again multiple
tasks they achieve strip properness and
strung truthfulness among symmetric
strategies they handle multi signal but
again they're working technically in
this asymptotic environment and for
multiple signals they need homogeneous
agents then the final paper I mention on
the theory side also by some people in
this room including Kostas it's it's a
different setting but I wanted to
mention it again I kind of I've pulled
it into the setting of my talk multiple
tasks the tasks have kind of a distinct
but known context what's interesting in
difference about their model is they
allow for non-binary effort all of these
other papers are implicitly thinking
about a binary effort context you ever
try to get the signal or you don't try
they're doing something more
sophisticated in that they get optimal
efforts in a unique and dominant
strategy equilibrium but the catch
relative to the work that I'm presenting
here and these other papers is that
they're ignoring the possibility of miss
reports and so in the sense of the the
the the definitions and this talk they
don't get either strength truthfulness
or it's a scheme proper there it's all
about effort finally I'll mention
Alice's paper of the back here so
there's a very nice experimental paper
by Alice and Andrew annealing and Ryan
that says this all matters they ran an
experiment on Amazon Mechanical Turk and
they showed that either somehow
participants seemed to go to the
uninformative equilibrium or they just
seemed confused
okay so this all seems to matter we
don't really seem to know how to design
these things what do we do okay so what
are we doing this paper okay so what do
we do in this paper so first of all we
study what we call the output agreement
mechanism it really takes the output
agreement idea the simple output
agreement scoring mechanism and takes it
to this multi signal
and-and-and-and use of it in the context
of a multi task setting this result will
achieve strict proper and strong
truthful for a multi signal setting but
it will require domains to be
categorical and I explain I'll explain
what I mean by that this result
generalizes the desk up to Gauche
results from binary signal to multi
signal you now allow me to use a little
bit of domain knowledge so I'm not going
to assume access to the full Joint
Distribution conceptually I'm going to
twist you that I know the structure of
correlation in the world then I can do
more than this we have what i'll
describe as a zero one mechanism which
provides in form truthfulness and
properness or general multi signal
domains and also handles heterogeneity
if it's giving you informed truthful not
strong truthful but I hope I managed to
convince you that in form truthful
itself seems an interesting concept and
then we have what we'll call the ABCD
mechanism hopefully you'll see why it's
not a very imaginative name which
provides strong truthfulness amongst
symmetric strategies again for general
multi signal domains with heterogeneous
agent types the curious thing about this
design is it's not proper so it's strong
true fall among symmetric strategies but
not proper however we can also show that
meaning that that truthful reporting is
not an equilibrium but we can also show
that all equilibrium are strictly worse
than true for play in a large system so
if you're following me that's kind of
like a prisoner's dilemma it's like
we if we somehow coordinate then we get
more payoff than if we deviate and play
the equilibrium so I don't know what to
say at this point about whether this is
practical or not seems like it's it's an
interesting empirical question we've
also done some empirical analysis so we
have access to around a hundred
questions across 30 exercises at around
17 MOOCs and altogether around three
hundred and twenty-five thousand pure
evaluation responses okay so now to get
to the model so the basic setup is going
to have two agents 1 & 2 you can think
about them as being drawn from a larger
population
there'll be tasks Kay there'll be at
least three tasks the signals I and J
are on the domain one through m and it
takes effort to acquire a signal we have
a Joint Distribution we don't need that
to be common knowledge we also don't
need that to be known by the designer
but we might need some of the structural
property of that to be known by the
designer and it may be asymmetric
crucially there are going to be some
tasks that will be overlapping and some
tasks that won't be overlapping so if
you just think about three tasks and two
agents
so these are the tasks imagine that
agent Juan is given these tasks and
agent 2 is given these tasks then this
is my shared task this is my task that
goes to agent 1 only and this is my task
that goes to agent 2 so what is multi
task peer prediction what we're gonna do
is for every shared task we're going to
compute a payment it will be the same
payments of both agents and it will use
the reports on that shared task the
report from the shared tasks and it will
use all of the reports that agent one
made on its own exclusive tasks and all
of the reports of agents who made on its
own exclusive test and that will that
will compute a payment on a shared task
and we'll add up the payments across all
of the shared tasks so the scheme will
decompose over shared tasks what is the
strategy a strategy might be randomized
so its strategy for agent one is denoted
F for agents who is denoted Jay and I
are is the probability of fine to report
are if your signal is I and G sub J R is
the probability of fine to report are if
your signal is J we can show that it's
without loss to a few tasks symmetric
strategies so we're not gonna need these
strategies to vary by the task I'm gonna
skip the technical reason for why that's
the case
and we have these two notions that you
should understand to be able to follow
the statements of the results
this one is what does they mean to have
an informed strategy this just means
that your conditional distribution
should should change for some pair of
signals I and J and then a truthful
strategy will denote by asterisk there
any questions about the setup of the
problem you know if humans do not know
which of the shared tasks you can think
about doing that bye-bye randomization
after the fact for example so think
about the task as here's an image is it
a cat or a dog and so I'm just going to
talk about during distributions and
signals but if you want to make it more
concrete the image could have a kind of
a a latent type which in this case I'd
save Iver
it's a cat or a dog and then you in a
conditionally independent way might and
a noisy way if it's a cat you have some
probability your fake cat and some
probability or say dog if you want to
make a concrete I can have images I can
have my images be associated with a
background distribution on the latent
type of the image and then you're a
sensor and you get a noisy sample of
that type but but I'm I'm not going to
go into the latent model I'm just going
to talk about joint signal distributions
so in the agent's mind is there is it a
joy like everybody has the common
distributions of
right right so I'm the the the technical
results will be stated as based Nash
equilibria however a word the D how I
use their their detail free so so that
the the though be specificity of the
distribution of the won't matter to you
playing in a particular way so I don't
need common knowledge but I need some
structural properties to be understood
yeah so that's what I was saying about
the binary effort model this is that she
uh my future work slide and there are
papers like Casas paper and other papers
so for example work by our Peter Goshen
I think Preston may have been involved
in those papers as well with more
sophisticated models of effort and also
the the kind of the contest literature
as well this literature oftentimes
actually if you read these papers you
won't see any mention of effort but I
think it's very helpful to think about
it is a binary effort model you I even
know nothing and therefore all you can
do is play not new form strategy or you
invest some cost and you you get a
signal you can't control how noisy that
is you get a signal and then you
condition your play on that signal
well I guess the main thing is that
you're suffering but in it determines
the prime mission as you get the signal
if you do get that the signal is exactly
like that yeah I mean you can imagine
multiple ways to model what it means to
have a non-binary effort model but I
don't have anything to say about that
here I just I haven't thought about
where for the results will generalize or
not yeah James we don't need to model it
because once we can show that let's say
there's a separation between being
truthful than anything else I can always
scale the payments now I'm not telling
you how to scale them but in principle
that's the idea right good so the only
thing the agents care about is money
they don't care about anything any
decision that's being made based on the
reports they do care about cost but I'm
not modeling that cost explicitly but
I'd like you to assume that the expected
payment for being truthful is greater
than your cost okay
truthful strategy so so so so in a
subjective perspective so cost of looks
on the image he says I see a cat so
truthful would mean you say cat okay
okay interesting so I don't want to go
deep into this I think these are great
discussions though but the way these
have been modeled is it's kind of you
see a signal you you may do a page and
update but you did receive a signal and
so you did receive the signal that said
cat it may be you may get a noisy signal
so so so sorry say it again it's a lab
or a label it's like you know you you
you look at an assignment and you you
think about what grade to give the
assignment that's your signal now
if the world is not very noisy then
everybody may strongly agree with you
but if the world noisy things might be
more spread and the agents may also vary
in taste should I think of the strategy
space as exactly the signal space one
flew in exactly yes yes
so the strategy space is the mapping
from a signal to a distribution on
signals 15 minutes let's see where am I
fly to 8 or something gonna try to push
out a little bit solution concepts yeah
so because the payments decomposed
across shared tasks we can do all of the
analysis in terms of the expected
payments on any given shared task so efg
is the expected payment for strategy
profile F and G on a share tasks and
port from the distribution the
interested in based Nash equilibrium so
this is a slide where I'll make things
form also hopefully this will explain
your question Nicole so properness means
that being truthful is an equilibrium if
you want strict properness you need a
strict inequality there here's the
strong truthfulness definition I think
you'll agree it is very strong it says
that the expected payment for being
truthful is at least as much as any of a
pair of strategies it says if there's a
tie so if this is an equality then F and
G must be a permutation strategy in fact
they must be the same permutation
strategy so we're not gonna have
anything to say about that but I think
you'll agree we can we can we can
dispense with that every nation of a
signal you've received so you play a by
action on the signal you've received
permutations yes equality
argumented why should people invest to
do the cost after you need a strict
separation but it only regards a
permutation and you can't play a
permutation if you don't have the signal
its permutation of the costly signal
you've acquired in particular an
uninformed strategy will be strictly
less than being truthful the only tie I
allow is regards to permutation
strategies and then there's other
property that we think of interesting is
in form truthfulness is slightly weaker
if it's the same so this is still weakly
true for every F and G but now if this
is an equality F and G had better both
be informed and so we still get the
strict separation between informs and
uninformed and by the way strong true
for us implies strict proper and inform
truthfulness implies proper ok let me
describe a family of mechanisms and
you'll agree they're quite simple
conceptually they'll be parameterize by
a score matrix s score matrix just a
mapping from pairs of signals to a score
and whereas we normally imagine in the
game examples I gave you earlier in my
talk we normally imagine just scoring
you on a task well we're now going to do
is we're going to assign agents to the
multiple tasks we're going to get the
reports you think about that happening
simultaneously on all the tasks I've
assigned the agent to do and then for
every shared task I'm gonna pay again
both agents 1 & 2 the score they get for
their reports on that share task - the
score for a random report that I pick
from the set I assigned to agent 1 and
the random report I pick from the said I
assigned to agent 2 so I look at a
shared task I say Costas and Eric both
provided a signal a report on this task
I school you on that and then I pick
something else you said about a
different task and something else that
Eric said about a different task at
random and then I offer and then I sub
correct that score so so by the way you
can also replace this with the empirical
average if you want to that doesn't
change the mathematics you can take all
LM has but I'd like you to imagine this
scheme what is this doing the intuition
hopefully you have here is that now this
is kind of rewarding the XS agreement
you get because of things that say being
correlated or as understanding the
correlation structure on the same task
and kind of only paying you for that
agreement over the agreement you're
getting even on things where you're
responding to a completely different
task so for example the thing we were
worried about earlier in the talk is
that you might just say one all the time
you just say one all the time here your
payment is zero
one on one and this is what I want do
you see that if you say one all the time
let's have knock that out where we're
assuming the agents don't get to
identify the share tasks and and if
you're if you're unhappy about that I
could say lots of things but one thing
I'll say is imagine that I actually
assign these tasks to every agent which
I wouldn't want to do in a big system
and then I randomize after the fact
so are you suing the because this is
susceptible to sedition down the signal
condition on the signal there's nothing
else you only have have the the signal
space so you know so and if you're
you're you don't have an arbitrarily
rich signal space you can report the
technical assumption that we need I
believe this is all we need is that you
don't know anything beyond the signal
you may be imagining something where
it's outside the model that let's take
that off offline but but it's all about
it but I think I've only got 10 minutes
so okay so hopefully you have a little
bit of intuition I should say this this
this basic idea is in the deaf group to
ghost paper
and as I say here if if in particular
the score matrix is the identity matrix
it only pays for agreement then meaning
it looks like an output agreement matrix
then this is exactly the multi signal
generalization of des Kip to gosh okay
think I want to just try to convey some
basic intuition for way we do our
analysis and this Delta matrix we found
really crucial so let me explain this
Delta matrix
oh so that's write down an expression
for the expected payment given strategy
pair F and G just algebra offices
nothing complicated here it turns out
this Delta R is going to be very
instructive so what's the expected
payment for a pair of strategies F and G
well this is going to represent the
expected payment on the shared task and
this is going to represent the expected
payment for kind of the L on the end
that I sampled at random from the other
task and so on the share task I'm going
to consider all possible IJ signal pairs
these are the signals the agents get
they've got this Joint Distribution here
and then for any given IJ signal pair
remember we get paid $1 if the score
matrix is the identity matrix if we
report the same signal so I'm gonna sum
out over all possible reports the
probability that the joint probability
that we both report that same that same
signal this is the amount I get paid on
share test and the amount I get paid in
that second part of the payment term has
a very similar form the only difference
is because these are now destroying
tasks I just use the marginal
probabilities whoo and so if you write
that down you get this expression so you
get a special that says the expected
payment for a strategy pair F G is the
sum over I J of this Delta IJ matrix and
then multiplied out with the product
with the sum product of these strategies
what is this Delta IJ is this
it's the let me draw this it's the joint
probability minus the products of the
marginal probabilities Delta matrix
what's going to be really important to
get the results on the paper is actually
the fine structure of this and what is
Delta IJ it's the joint probability is
the product of the module another way to
write this is TI x PJ given I minus PJ
so in other words Delta IJ is positive
if the conditional probability of the
other agent getting J conditional are
you getting I is larger than the
marginal probability of J so in other
words Delta IJ is positive when this
positive correlation when when you
receiving this signal increases the
conditional the the condition
probability the other agent receiving
that signal one is larger than the
marginal problems and so you might think
that so that the world matrices might
look like this this is what we actually
call in the paper a categorical domain
so this is the domain where we have
correlation we have we have positive
correlation on the leading diagonal and
then we have negative correlation
everywhere else so if I think the grade
is long then the conditional probability
that the other agent will think the
grade is long is higher than the
marginal probability and the conditional
probability the other agent will think
the grade is two is lower than the
marginal property the same for through
so think about a categorical domain that
we tend to have this type of structure
for example an image labeling domain
where I show you a picture and I ask you
how does this creature move around the
world does it fly does it swim or does
it walk there you might expect this type
of domain because you might think that
the disagreements are kind of happening
in an unstructured way relative to what
you think the signal is whereas in a
grading setting let's say the grade is
on a scale from 1 to 100 if I think this
the correct number is 75
might increase the probability that
Kostas thinks the correct number is 75
but it might also increase the problems
he thinks the correct number 76 or 77 or
78 do you think about that more as an
ordinal domain whether symmetric space
that the the signals are embedded in and
so this is a categorical domain we want
to get positive results and if you're
wondering the expression for expected
payment generalizes in a clean way to
settings where the score matrix is zero
okay so in the interest of time I think
I'm gonna tell you the main results
did you just a quick look at the
empirical results and then I'll wrap up
I've got about five minutes we can show
that it's sufficient to focus on
deterministic strategies I'm going to
skip the technical reason why
which ends up actually being very useful
to some refine our analysis me tell you
our results so the first results is the
Oh a mechanism which is the direct
generalization of the desktop to Gersh
mechanism is strict proper and strongly
true for if the world is categorical and
we show that this is tight as well and
we obtain their results as a corollary
of that results I'm gonna skip the
analysis but it's it's very
straightforward it all fits on a slide
so you might say okay are we done so I
say I know how to design a multi signal
scheme of the properties I care about as
long as the world is categorical our
world categorical so we went into our
data from these exercises across a
number of different MOOCs and first of
all we asked for the questions here for
example the questions might be like this
this is one where there are three
possible signals and you're asked to
score the students on not much of a
style at all communicative style or
strong flowing writing style correlating
two signals one two or three so this
would be a world where there are three
possible signals and we're ordering the
results that I'm showing you here by the
number of signals in the world and first
of all we have strong a one of the
worlds have positive correlation meaning
that we have positives on the leading
diagonal however the majority of the
world for non categorical meaning we
also have positives off the leading
diagonal which means that we're not done
means that the output agreement
mechanism generalizing descriptor Gosha
is not enough so the second mechanism we
have modifies the scoring matrix like
this so it says if this is the structure
of Delta this is the score matrix you
should use
I long for their pluses and zeroth
whether in negatives the theorem for
general domains this zero one mechanism
is informed truthful and proper then
skip the proof argument but again it
fits here so this Delta analysis is
really helping to prove these results
and then the final mechanism so what
some study secretary about this
well you might tell me the new form of
truthfulness is not enough and I think
in particular if I drop outside of a
binary effort model I would agree with
you so let's see what else we can do the
ABCD mechanism now you see why the 8th
of these of seasons the DS has four
different numbers and the payoff matrix
and just to give you an example suppose
that the Delta matrix looks like
suppose the Delta matrix looks like this
then the score define the score matrix
defined in the ABCD mechanism is going
to put let's say ABCD are 0 1 2 3 it's
going to use the B and the C on the
leading diagonal and it's going to use
the C whether a positive so it's going
to do 2 to 2 on the leading diagonal and
then off the leading diagonal it's going
to use the 0 and the 3 and it's going to
use the 0 for negatives and the 3 for
positives for matrix there would
correspond from this Delta matrix didn't
need one because there was no negative
on the leading diagonal okay so what's
the theorem the ABCD mechanism is strong
truthful among symmetric strategies so
now it's a slightly weaker strong
truthfulness claim it's not across all
FG path just symmetric FG PEs and I
didn't say proper so this is the thing
that as she is curious so half times get
into the details but it's not proper
however any equilibrium in a large
economy has strictly less payment than
playing truthfully so this has the
prisoner's dilemma flavour to it so you
might think this is actually a good
mechanism we won't know until we try it
ok let me just let you work a little bit
at we had a hundred and four different
questions so these are the Delta
matrices across 104 different questions
across the 17 MOOCs and the reason I'm
showing you leaves these are these are
questions where it was it was true/false
so you see they have the positive is red
negative is blue they have the the
categorical structure the three by
threes also generally have the
categorical structure so you see red on
the leading diagonal and blues off but
when you go to four by fours you see
this kind of thicker red
and on the leading diagonal it's a non
categorical meaning meaning the types of
things happening that I described
earlier so I have some more things to
tell you about that but I'll skip it
there's a review of our results let me
spend a minute on discussion that's okay
Eric so here here is where I think we
stand and here is some future directions
is there a proper and strong truthful
perhaps strong truthful amongst only
symmetric strategies mechanism for
general domains as a result of not
exhaustive literature one thing I wanted
to note is that you can generalize the
mechanism by describes by using a
different score matrix for the shared
tasks and the non-shared tasks we don't
know yet whether that will help can
heterogeneity be handled in a sense we
can already handle heterogeneity because
I need to know the plus/minus structure
of the Delta matrix but you can imagine
that it becomes less and less plausible
for me to know that matrix as the world
becomes more hedge to hedge
heterogeneous so the mental model I like
to adopt here is if I can learn
something about your taste then I want
to try to align you with the taste of a
canonical agent so so I'll take the
reports from one agent reports from
another agent I'll kind of realign them
so that they match better make the world
look more categorical I think that's an
interesting direction to be able to
handle heterogeneity in an either way if
they're a prior free design for example
could we use observed data to then
ex-post design the score matrix would we
get the same technical results we don't
know at this point what about population
learning we haven't talked about this in
this workshop we've been oftentimes
assuming equilibrium but I think that
most of us really believe that
equilibria are probably not just played
through introspection now this is a very
high-stakes environment I think we
probably believe that they're important
because it's where the world will ends
up with enough time maybe we don't even
believe they're important even with that
but so what if we modeled replicator
dynamics on these with the world go in
the right direction we have some results
on that but I won't show you in the
interest
I'm richer models of effort we talked
about and then I think these things are
ready to be tested experimented with and
applied so thank you